ja wie immer willkommen zur Vorlesung
und wie immer
unser begriffsnetz das werden sie
langsam schon auswendig kennen ich spule
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen vor ich
habe gehört im Tutorium es gab noch ein
bisschen ungleich Unklarheiten auf der
linken Seite der freiheitsseite
da wo er der Begriff der Notwendigkeit
man nicht ganz klar also das betrifft
jetzt diese drei
Bereiche die ich jetzt hier
hervorhebe mit dem Laserpointer dem
virtuellen determination Notwendigkeiten
Differenz damit ist einfach gesagt diese
drei Begriffe der termination das alles
in der Welt bestimmt ist manchmal
spricht man auch von Satz des zu
reichenden Grundes Leibnitz spricht
davon und der Notwendigkeit oder in
Differenz die stehen in einer gewissen
Spannung zum Begriff der Willensfreiheit
das heißt nicht dass die unbedingt den
Begriff der Willensfreiheit dem
widersprechen am ehesten tut es die
Notwendigkeit zählen sich Leibnitz hat
die gesagt
Notwendigkeit verträgt sich mit
Willensfreiheit überhaupt nicht es war
die These von Leibnitz es gibt aber auch
andere Theorien die sagen Freiheit ist
gerade Notwendigkeit das heißt wenn da
eine Frage dran käme in der Klausur wäre
das natürlich eine Frage des Typs B was
ich jetzt aber noch mehr erklären möchte
ist aber man kann jetzt diese drei
Begriffe determination Notwendigkeit und
Indifferenz mit Blick auf das Thema
Willensfreiheit problematisieren kann
sich zum Beispiel fragen inwiefern
verträgt sich Willensfreiheit mit der
termination und wie weit verträgt sie
sich mit Notwendigkeit und inwiefern
verträgt sie sich mit Indifferenz
Indifferenz ist ein Zustand der mehr
oder weniger keine zu reichenden Gründe
für die eine oder andere Option hat
manchmal spricht man auch von in der
Termin ist ja oder sogar noch schlimmer
von Blusen Zufall bloße Beliebigkeit
damals natürlich wieder den Begriff der
Willkür der hier drauf bezogen werden
kann eigentlich könnte hier eigentlich
um Differenz und will für eine gewisse
Verbindung
sie sich aber auch selbst ziehen wenn
sich das ganze mal ausdrucken und
weitere Anmerkung einfügen das ist soll
nicht heißen dass das abgeschlossen ist
das begriffsnetz kann immer weiter
gesponnen werden weiter vernetzt werden
sie können sich selbst ausdrucken können
sich eigene neue Verbindungslinien oder
auch Oppositionen selbst einzeichnen das
würde ich sowieso empfehlen also das
natürlich nur sagen der terminationen
Notwendigkeit Notwendigkeit ist noch
stärker als der termination in der
Philosophie Geschichte wird gesagt
häufig kompatibilismus ja also das
Bildungsfreiheit und der termination
miteinander vereinbar sind
erlaubt die Wahrheit ist der terminismus
also der Determinismus kann wahr sein
alles in der Welt kann der terminiert
sein und trotzdem ist willensfrei
möglich mit der Notwendigkeit ist es
schon etwas schwieriger also
Notwendigkeit ist noch stärker als bloße
determination weil Notwendigkeit heißt
es muss genau so sein und es ist nicht
möglich dass es anders wird
denken sie noch mal an den Begriff der
möglichen Welt ich bin da kurz darauf
eingegangen bei Leibnitz mögliche Welten
mögliche Welten sind Welten die logisch
widerspruchsfrei gedacht werden können
also eine mögliche Welt ist zum Beispiel
eine Welt in der hier hinten keine
Gebäude stehen das ist logisch möglich
die Welt wäre logisch denkbar wenn hier
keine Gebäude stehen das würde unserer
Vernunft nicht widersprechen und ist es
eben so kontingenter Weise also nicht
notwendigerweise aber es ist möglich
dass sie Gebäude stehen und tatsächlich
stehende Gebäude aber das ist nicht
notwendig das heißt es ist der
terminierte Zustand er hat seine zu
reichen Gründe alles hatte Gründe das
ist dazu kam dass hier Gebäude gebaut
wurden die Gründe kann man erzählen eine
große Geschichte da gab es bestimmt
Entscheidungen es gibt bestimmte Gründe
dafür dass hier ein Gebäude gebaut wurde
ich verstehe die Gründe im Einzel nicht
aber es gibt sie sonst werden die
Gebäude nicht da aber es ist nicht so
dass die Gebäude notwendigerweise
verstehen müssen die könnten auch
irgendwo anders stehen also es ist nicht
notwendig es ist so Notwendigkeit gibt
sagt zumindest Leibnitz immer dann da wo
wir es zum Beispiel mit mathematischen
Notwendigkeiten zu tun haben oder
logisch Notwendigkeiten es gibt also
keine mögliche Welt sagt Leibnitz in der
ein Dreieck zumindest in der zweiten
Dimensionen das ist ein flaches Dreieck
eine Winkelsumme hat von mehr oder
weniger als 180 Grad das ist ganz
notwendig in allen möglichen Welten und
Leibnitz hat jetzt eine solche
Notwendigkeit z.B eine mathematische
oder geometrische Notwendigkeit die in
allen möglichen Welten der Fall ist die
verträgt sich nicht mit Willensfreiheit
weil dann gibt's keine Alternativität
dann muss es so sein es gibt keine
alternativen Szenarien ja das ist so der
Gedanke der dahinter steckt hinter dem
Begriff der Notwendigkeit das ist also
in allen möglichen Welten so sein muss
und nicht nur in ein paar Möglichkeiten
wie eben die determinierten zustimmen
das heißt notwend Möglichkeit ist ein
viel stärkerer Begriff als der der
determination und deswegen kann man auch
häufig kompatibilismus vertreten eine
kompatibilistische Theorie die sagt
Willensfreiheit verträgt sich mit der
determination weil es könnte auch ganz
anders sein es muss nicht sein dagegen
gibt es inkompatibilismus der sagt der
termination und willensweit vertragen
sich auf keine Weise also entweder das
eine ist war der terminismus oder die
wir jetzt Freiheit aber beides zusammen
können wir nicht hinbekommen wir können
das nicht kompatibilistisch sehen
deswegen sagt man ein inkompatibilismus
und da gibt es eben zwei Möglichkeiten
ein harte Determinismus der sagt alles
ist ganz eindeutig bestimmt festgelegt
redefiniert sogar schon vor unsere
Geburt sehen sich das Konsequenz
Argument vor unsere Geburt war das schon
alles determiniert so dass wieder auch
nichts mehr dran ändern können ähm es
liegt nicht in unseren Entscheidungen
weil es vor unsere Geburt schon bestimmt
war das der hatte der terminismus der
sagt wenn es ist nicht möglich weil eben
alles so hart determiniert ist schon für
unsere Geburt und dann gibt es den
libertarianismus der sagt der
Determinismus ist falsch es ist gar
nicht so dass alles eindeutig bestimmt
ist man kann sich darauf Quanten
Zustände Berufen auf Zustände in der
Natur die nicht eindeutig bestimmt sind
man kann es versuchen mit dem
theologischen Argument auf Aristoteles
zurückgehen und sagen es gibt noch eine
zweckausalität nicht der
wirkübersichtlichkeit aufgeht gibt es
ganz verschiedene Möglichkeiten ähm
lieber Tage nicht muss zu vertreten das
ist so das Konzept der Freiheit und dann
haben wir in den letzten Sitzungen und
verstärkt mit dem Thema Emotionen
beschäftigt und es gibt natürlich eine
riesen Debatte was jetzt Emotionen sind
wie man sie von Affekten von Stimmungen
und Gefühlen unterscheiden muss
letztendlich ist es eine
reintunologische Debatte es geht aber
den Sinn dahinter und wir hatten gesehen
beginnt das manche Philosophen Harry
Fremdwort ist eine aber auch Friedrich
Schiller auf den kommen heute noch mal
zu sprechen dass die gesagt haben die
Liebe als Emotion kann uns Gründe für
unser Handeln zur Verfügung stellen und
zwar solche Gründe dass wir wenn wir im
Zustand der Liebe sind im Zustand der
Liebe handeln dass wir darin autonom
sind also wir können hier noch ein weil
sie von Autonomie zu Liebe und Grund das
hatte Harry Fremdwort gesagt und es ist
nicht so dass wir in der Liebe nicht
ganz zurechenbar sind weil uns irgendwie
die Emotion mit uns durchgehen das wäre
ja auch eine Ansicht von von Liebe dass
man sagt dann sind wir gar nicht frei in
der Liebe das immer völlig von Sinnen
also immer nicht her und zwar selbst
aber es gibt eben je nachdem wie man
jetzt lieber auffasst
eine Auffassung dass man sagt in der
Liebe drücken wir uns selbst aus wir
drücken unser eigenes innerliches aus
und wir fühlen uns seine anderen Person
verpflichtet so dass wir sie nicht nur
instrumentalisieren sondern ihr einen an
sich zu schreiben und das führt
natürlich wieder deine gewisse Nähe zum
Gebot des kategorischen Imperativs das
wäre eine andere Person nicht immer nur
als Mittel zum Zweck sondern eben auch
immer zugleich als Selbstzweck als
absoluten Zweck beim eins Zweck an sich
selbst mit einer absoluten würde
verstehen soll Achtung ist auch noch so
ein Kandidat der häufig mit Blick auf
die Autonomie angeführt wird von dem
markant und es gibt natürlich dann noch
die Frage nach der moralischen
Motivation wie ich Emotionen motiviert
uns am besten und wir haben doch dritten
Kandidaten neben der Liebe und der
Achtung kennengelernt nämlich das
Mitleid und da möchte ich heute auch
noch ein bisschen mehr drauf eingehen da
ist natürlich Auto Schopenhauer der
Zentrale Philosoph der hier genannt
werden muss wenn es um das Mitleid geht
jetzt möchte noch einen kleinen
Nachmittag geben noch mal zur
Notwendigkeit einfach das ist mal kurz
also das freiheitsproblem mit dem wir
uns auch hier herumgeschlagen haben ist
eines der schwierigsten Probleme
überhaupt und deswegen hat auch Leibniz
davon gesprochen im Sinne eines
Labyrinth es gibt zwei berühmte
Labyrinthe in denen sich unsere sehr oft
verirrt das eine betrifft die große
Frage nach dem freien und notwendigen
vor allem bei der Entstehung dem
Ursprung des Bösen das andere Labyrinth
besteht in der Erörterung der
Kontinuität und der Unteilbarkeit das
zweite muss uns nächstes Jahr
beschäftigen das erste Labyrinth ist das
Wesen der Freiheit und des Verhältnis zu
Notwendigkeit natürlich auch zu
determination das können sich gut merken
freiheit ist ein Labyrinth
da verirrt man sich sehr schnell und da
findet man vielleicht gar nicht mehr
raus deswegen ist unser Begriff nicht so
wichtig dass Sie immer wieder den roten
Faden aus dem Labyrinth finden aber eine
definitive Antwort auf diese
Freiheitsfrage hat es bisher noch nicht
gegeben und wird wahrscheinlich auch
nicht geben es geht nicht darum hier die
einzig wahre Antwort zu finden sondern
sich zu orientieren diesen Labyrinth
welche verschiedenen Positionen kann ich
vertreten was spricht für die eine
Position und was spricht für die andere
Position so würde ich das labyrin
verstehen es geht um Orientierung in den
verschiedenen Begriffen den
Grundbegriffen der praktischen
Philosophie es bringe ich den Rückblick
wir hatten uns gefragt worin sich
moralische Gefühle oder eben genau
gesagt Emotionen und unterscheiden
Mitleid Achtung und Liebe sind so drei
paradigmatische Gefühle oder ich sag ihr
Emotionen die uns motivieren können die
moralisch sind und ein anderes Gefühl
oder Emotion vielleicht besser ist der
Neid darüber haben wir auch diskutiert
ganz kurz und die Diskussion um den Neid
der für mich so eine beispielhafte
unmoralische Emotion ist ich halte Neid
deswegen so spannend weil wir dahin so
unmoralisch sind und weil der Neid zu
alltäglich ist diese Debatte um den Leid
als unmoralische Emotionen wie ich ihn
bezeichnen würde diese Debatte werden
wir in einer eigenen Sitzung im neuen
Jahr weiterführen nämlich wenn es um
Gerechtigkeit geht ich glaube dass die
leitproblematik ganz eng mit dem Thema
Gerechtigkeit zusammenhängt wir haben
auch das letzte Mal darüber kurz
diskutiert
ja jetzt möchte ich noch mal zum Mitleid
was nachliefern das haben wir alles
schon gehört Arthur Schopenhauer sagt
Mitleid ist der Grausamkeit
entgegengesetzt Grausamkeit ist das
Schlimmste überhaupt was es gibt im
moralische Hinsicht und wenn Mitleid des
Gegenteil von Grausamkeit ist dann folgt
daraus dass Mitleid des moralisch Beste
ist was es überhaupt gibt ne wenn es
genau das Gegenteil von Grausamkeit ist
Grausamkeit schlimmste ist muss Mitleid
das Beste sein darüber kann natürlich
noch treffen streiten das machen wir
auch also jetzt möchte ich Ihnen hier
ein neues Zitat nachliefern das ist ein
bisschen länger ich habe zwei das erste
ist kurz er sagt erstmal Schuppen haben
Mitleid ist ein Gegengewicht des
brennenden Egoismus der alle Wesen
erfüllt und auf dem Boden halt übergeht
also das Argument von Schopenhauer ist
das an das Mitleid deswegen so wichtig
ist für uns als moralische Emotion weil
es uns hilft uns Egoismus also unsere an
Auffassung dass wir als individo
besondere Bedeutung hätten zu überwinden
dafür ist sagt jetzt Schopenhauer des
Mitleid ganz zentral und jetzt kommt ein
längeres Zitat das möchte ich Ihnen aber
nicht vorenthalten weil darin ist jetzt
so die ganze Essenz seiner Theorie des
Mitleids angelegt ist ist eine ganz
tiefe Theorie und ich hatte ihn schon
angedeutet dass Schopenhauer hier auch
Elemente der indische
Philosophie der weden einbezieht und das
möchte ich Ihnen jetzt mal vorlesen wenn
nämlich vor den Augen eines Menschen
jeder jeder Schleier der Maja ich komme
noch genauer drauf was der Meyer die
maja ist so sehr gelüftet ist dass
derselben nicht mehr den egoistischen
Unterschied zwischen seiner Person und
der fremden Macht sondern an den Leiden
der anderen Individuen so viel Anteil
nimmt wie an seinen eigenen und dadurch
nicht nur am höchsten geraden hilfreich
ist sondern da bereit sein ist
Individuum zu opfern sobald mehrere
fremde dadurch zu retten sind dann folgt
von selbst dass ein solcher Mensch der
in allen Wesen sieht sein Innerstes und
wahre Selbst erkennt auch die endlosen
leiden alles lebenden als die seinen
betrachten und so den Schmerz der ganzen
Welt sich zu eignen muss bis dahin
reichts mal an sie könnte es noch in
aller Ruhe weiter lesen dann ich stell
dir vorhin noch auf
Ilias der Schleier der Mai das ist ein
interessante Theorie nämlich der
Schleier der Bayer besagt nach der
theoretischen Philosophie der
altindischen Philosophie das wir in
unserer normalen Welt getäuscht werden
wir werden getäuscht in dem wir glauben
dass wir einzelne Wesen sein die von
anderen Wesen Unterschieden sein
Schopenhauer spricht auch hier weiter
unten vom Prinzipien Individuation ist
vom
individuationsprinzip als von dem was
uns Individuen machen und das sagt
Schopenhauer und da knüpft dann die
indische Philosophie an das ist nur ein
Schein dass wir Individuen sein weil wir
im Grunde alle vereint zu denken sind
und nicht mehr als Individuum im Grund
sondern eine Einheit eigentlich immer
eingehen und im Mitleid sagte
tropenhauer im Mitleid erkennen wir
punktuell nur in bestimmten Situationen
dass wir eigentlich alle leiden
leidensfähige und leidende Wesen sind
und dass wir sogar im Mitleid es
schaffen über unseren Egoismus
hinauszugehen und dieses
individuationsprinzip zu überwinden hin
zu einer Identifikation mit allen
Menschen weil sie leidenfähig sind und
nicht nur mit allen Menschen sondern
überhaupt mit allem leidensfähigen was
es auf der Welt gibt in der aktuellen
Debatte nennt man das patozentrismus
pathozentrismus heißt es geht darum dass
wir das Leiden oder die Leidensfähigkeit
Zentrum stehen da stellen darum geht es
dazu zählen natürlich auch nicht
menschliche Tiere das ist hier zu sein
Argument das all das Mitleid deswegen so
stark ist weil es uns mit der ganzen
Menschheit darüber hinaus mit allem was
leiden kann
identifizieren können unseren die ganze
Welt den Schmerz der ganzen Welt und
zueignen können wenn wir das können dann
sagt Schopenhauer dann sind wir darin
gerade moralisch weil dann interessiert
uns nämlich die andere Person plötzlich
und wir überwinden unseren Egoismus der
leider in uns allen sehr sehr kräftig
enthalten ist und darüber diskutieren
wir jetzt mal kurz
die Theorie des Mitleids ist nicht
unkritisiert geblieben und das ist
natürlich auch eine spannende Frage die
ein Typ der eine Frage des Typs B dann
bezeichnet ich Argumente sprechen zum
Beispiel für Mitleid und gegenmitleid da
kann man ein bisschen abwägen ja spricht
ja einiges dafür aber auch vielleicht
einiges dagegen und die Manuel kann
zeigt eben ist der spricht was dagegen
er sagt dieses Gefühl des Mitleids und
der weichherzigen teilnehmen wenn es vor
der Überlegung was Pflichtteil vorher
geht Bestimmungsgrund wird also Motiv
bewegungsgrund unseres Lebens wird ist
wohl denken eine Personen also
Individuen Personen sind immer
Individuum selbst lästig bringt ihre
überlegte Maximen in Verwirrung und
bewirkt den Wunsch ihre entledigt und
allein der gesetzgebenden Vernunft
unterworfen zu sein dann sagt der
Mitleid empfindet wir Mitleid an die
erste Stelle setzt was moralische
Emotionen gelangt oder moralischen
Motivation der macht eigentlich nur so
ein im Prinzip der weichherzigen
teilnehmen zum ersten Maßstab und
Weichherzigkeit das ist ganz subjektiv
da vielleicht habe ich mit diesem
einwiesen mehr Mitleid weil es mir
ähnlicher sieht vielleicht habe ich mit
Säugetieren mehr Mitleid weil sie mir
irgendwie
evolutionsbiologischen her stehen als
Reptilien ja also kann kritisiert er
Mitleid dass es nicht objektiv ist das
Mitleid sagt Schopenhauer es erkannt hat
gar keine eigenen Gründe wir können das
gar nicht rechtfertigen das ist allein
bloße Subjektivität vielleicht sogar
einfach auch nur im schlecht schlechten
Sinne Sympathie ne dieses Wesen sieht
einfach sympathisch aus es entspricht
dem Kindchenschema und deswegen habe ich
mit dem mehr Mitleid als mit einem Wesen
was vielleicht viel mehr leidet aber
eben nicht in mein Schema passt ist mir
nicht Sympath es sieht nicht sympathisch
aus und deswegen habe ich mit ihm kein
Mitleid das kritisiert kann Mitleid ist
sub aktiv ist relativ ist zu sehr von
unseren individuellen Neigung abhängig
also kann wendet eine Schopenhauer gegen
sich selbst und sagt im Mitleid lassen
wir gerade nicht unseren Individualismus
hinter uns zu einem in den Mitleid
zeigen wir gerade unsere
individualistische Seite weil wir eben
Sympathien empfinden Sympathien sind
immer ganz individuelle Natur also Kant
würde schunkenhow direkt versuchen zu
widerlegen konnte er nicht bei
Schopenhauer natürlich jünger war als
kann sie haben sich sicherlich
überschnitten ein bisschen aber meines
Wissens sind sie nicht großartig in
Kontakt gekommen ja also das wäre wäre
Argument gegen das Mitleid da
übersteigen wenn ich unsere
Individualismus unseren Egoismus sondern
Mitleid
rückwirkungismus auf eine besonders
sympathisierende Weise aus deswegen so
sagt Kant können wir da nicht Mitleid
als eigentliches moralisches
motivationsprinzip gut
Liebe ist natürlich auch noch so ein Tod
und
da sagt aber Kant auch es ist sehr schön
aus Liebe zu Menschen und teilnehmenden
Gutes zu tun oder aus Liebe zu ordnen
gerecht zu sein aber das ist noch nicht
die echte moralische Maxime unseres
Verhaltens die unserem Standpunkt unter
vernünftigen Wesen als Menschen
angemessen ist also auch liebe sagt kann
ist wie Mitleid ganz ähnlich viel zu
subjektiv es hat viel zu wenig Gründe
und es sind eigentlich ist eigentlich
Neigung und und die Vernunft kommt hier
in der Liebe wie bei Mitleid zu kurz
kann man natürlich jetzt kritisieren
schiller hat das gemacht er hat gesagt
die Liebe ist eine freie Empfindung also
in der Liebe das immer nicht nur
emotionale Wesen die ihre individuellen
Präferenzen Sympatien ausdrücken sondern
noch viel mehr in der Liebe sind wir
freiwillig und er konkretisierte sie
sagt das Gemüt ist auf gelöst in der
Liebe und es ist in der Achtung
angespannt also liebe ist ein Zustand
unserer freien Moral wo Vernunft
Überlegung Rationalität und
Emotionalität in einer harmonischen
Einheit sind und so sollte Moral sein
und nicht nur auf der emotionalen Seite
aber auch nicht nur auf der rationalen
Seite weil wir da sagt Schiller
innerlich zerrissen sind aber sie haben
mir keine innere Harmonie und Moral ist
für Schiller immer etwas was harmonisch
sein sollte und nie unter Druck welche
Art auch immer zustande kommen sollte
auch nicht unter Druck der Vernunft und
dem kategorischen Imperativ der uns
natürlich etwas absolut gebetet und das
ist sagt kann selbst eine Form des
Zwangs und Schiller sagt nein nein nein
nein nein nein Moralität und zwang
vertragen sich überhaupt nicht Qualität
muss Harmonie sein das wird zu einem
anderen Thema auf dass wir heute auch
noch eingehen werden nämlich auf das
Thema Normativität sie haben den Begriff
schon mal gehört Ende der heutigen
Sitzung komm mal kurz darauf zu sprechen
und in der virtuellen ersatzsitzung
morgen die sich schon auf Ilias finden
habe ich dazu noch ausführlicher was
gesagt Schiller würde sagen Normativität
also dasjenige was unser Handeln
anleitet das was uns die Richtschnur die
Orientierung von Sachen gibt das sollte
nie so sein dass wir darin in einem
zwangszustand sind welche aber doch
immer so Normativität muss immer
bedeuten dass wir darin im Handeln
harmonisch handeln und ausgeglichen
Handeln in einer Einheit mit uns selbst
sind und Hand hat eben das die Achtung
ins Zentrum gestellt der hat gesagt die
Achtung ist das ausgezeichnete
moralische Gefühl ich würde sagen die
ausgezeichnete moralische Motivation das
hat eigentlich ist achtung die
Vorstellung von einem Werte der meine
Selbstliebe also meinem Egoismus
Abbruch tut also der mein Egoismus
erniedrigt das was ja auch Schopenhauer
wollte durch das Mitleid dass der
Egoismus besiegt wird und kann sagt die
Achtung die die besiegt auch mein
Egoismus also ist es etwas was weder als
Gegenstand der Neigung weil es ja meine
Egoismus Abbruch tut kann ich es nicht
neigungsmäßig wollen noch der Furcht
betrachtet wird obgleich ist mit beiden
zugleich etwas analogisches hat der
Gegenstände Achtung ist also lediglich
das moralische Gesetz unserer dasjenige
was wir uns selbst und doch als an sich
notwendig auferlegen also wir achten in
der Achtung wenn wir moralisch Achtung
haben achten die eigentlich das Gebot
des Sittengesetzes und darin achten wir
eigentlich uns selbst aber als
moralische vernünftige Wesen und nicht
als empirische Wesen die neigen
empfinden können weil ja die achten wie
kann selbst sagt mit unserer Selbstliebe
kollidiert also Achtung bedeutet wenn
wir
ist hier nicht darum geht was wir als
Individuum sind was wir können unseren
individuellen Eigenschaften zählen
überhaupt nicht im Zustand der Achtung
sondern es zählt nur das moralische
Vorbild
orientiere ich mich Angebot des
kategorischen Imperativs also ein sehr
starkes Vernunft Interesse ist darin
ausgedrückt in der Achtung und es ist
eine Spannung weil er sagt ja es kommt
darin äh sowas wie Furcht und
durch ist darin enthalten in der Achtung
und das ist natürlich ein Zustand der
nach Schiller nicht harmonisch zu
begrüßen wird aber wir natürlich uns in
der Achtung auch selbst erniedrigen
sofern wir einen sinnliches tierisches
Wesen sind
den Neid bin ich schon eingegangen den
überspringe ich mal und jetzt möchte ich
noch mal ein bisschen genauer auf dieses
Thema moralische Motivation eingehen
aber ich würde auch noch mal ganz kurz
hier zu Kant eine kleine
Diskussionsphase einbauen
genau wir gehen jetzt noch mal auf die
eigentliche Frage nach moralischen
Motivation zurück die Frage ist hier das
Grundproblem ist das wie können wir
unseren so bestimmen dass er zu einer
Handlung führt
dass unser Wille handlungswirksam wird
wie können rationale und normative
Gründe wir sind schon auf Gründe
eingegangen es gibt verschiedene Arten
von Gründen oder Perspektiven auf Gründe
wie können rationale vernünftige und
normative Gründe also Gründe die
zwingende Gründe sind die gute Gründe
sind wie können die auch motivationale
Gründe sein wie kann aus seinem Grund
der was kognitives ist ja ein Grund ist
ja etwas was in einem was ein mentaler
Zustand ist ja also spricht etwas für
etwas wie kann der so beschaffen sein
dass er mehr oder weniger nicht mit
meinem Kopf bleibt im mentalen Bereich
sondern dass er eine Art von Energie
entwickelt um hinaus in die Welt zu
einer äußeren Handlung zu führen wir
haben auch schon über innere Hand
gesprochen hier geht es jetzt in der
Regel um äußere also die zu einer
Bewegung führen dass ich etwas vollziehe
in der Außenwelt wie können Gründe zur
motivationalen Quelle werden und genauer
gesagt kann man dich fragen wie führen
können moralische Gründe also natürlich
auch normative Gründe wir kommen noch
auf das Begriff des normativen zu
sprechen also gute Gründe wie können
moralische Gründe die eben normative
Gründe sind moralischer Hinsicht wie
können die auch motivationale Gründen
also wie kann ich aus der Erkenntnis
dass jetzt alles für diese Handlung
spricht dass alle Gründe in der Waage
für diese Handlungsoption
letztendlich sprechen oder wiegen
als moralische Gründe sind weil ich sehe
diese Gründe sind die richtigen Gründe
die Situation mit welchen Mittel auch
immer mit dem kategorischen Imperativ
mit dem verallgemeinerungsverfahren
schlagschale senken in eine Richtung wie
kann ich dann daraus noch eine
Motivation gewinnen oder ist diese Frage
völlig überflüssig wenn die Waagschale
in eine Richtung lenkt neigt sich neigt
stark genug dann habe ich darin schon
die Motivation zu könnte man natürlich
auch sagen aber muss schon sagen Gründe
sind das eine und Motivationen und
Kräfte sind noch mal was anderes also
zumindest begrifflich kann man da noch
mal unterscheiden und jetzt ist eben die
Frage wie finden können moralischen
motivationale Gründe mentale Zustände
die für etwas sprechen wie können die
oder inwiefern können die Emotionen sein
oder selbst sich vielleicht genauer
gesagt in Emotionen ausdrücken und
artikulieren also gibt es Emotionen die
genau diesen Gründen entsprechend deren
Ausdruck dieser Gründe sind weil dann
hätte ich nämlich sehr leicht diese
motivationale Kraft die mich motiviert
weil wir gesehen haben Emotionen sind
zuständig die energetisch sind Emotionen
geben uns sehr viel Kraft zum Handeln
aber geben Sie uns auch Gründe zum
Handeln dass die spannende Frage aus
Emotionen kann ich sehr viel tun noch
viel mehr oder viel schneller kann ich
was im Effekt tun aber im Affekt habe
ich eigentlich keine Gründe für die Hand
gehabt im Affekt wenn ich da etwas getan
habe was ganz harmloses beleidige eine
Person das bereue ich häufig sehr
schnell wenn ich das im Affekt getan
habe weil dann muss ich sagen ich hatte
eigentlich keine Gründe das zu tun da
waren keine Gründe involviert und jetzt
kann man sich fragen gibt es Emotionen
die Gründe ausdrücken oder
repräsentieren dass ich sage wenn ich
aus dieser emotionalen Haltung heraus
oder in diesen emotionalen Zustand
heraus etwas getan habe weil die mir
natürlich die Kraft gegeben haben die
Emotionen waren dann da noch Gründe mit
dem Spiel vertragen sich diese Emotionen
verträgt sich diese konkrete Emotion mit
bestimmten Gründen für diese haben und
das ist eben die Frage die wieder auf
diese drei Emotionen
führt Mitleid Liebe und Achtung die
Frage ist die welche Emotion eignet sich
am besten dazu uns moralisch zu
motivieren welche Emotion noch eine
weitere Frage drückt unser eigenes Wesen
im Grunde aus sodass wir darin autonomen
hat wir haben schon gesehen perfekt sind
wir meistens nicht ganz bei uns selbst
wenn sie was in Affekt tun würden sie
häufig danach sagen das war nicht ich da
ist irgendwas mit mir durchgegangen da
war ich nicht ganz Herrin oder Herr
meiner selbst ja das widerspricht dem
Gedanken der Autonomie wenn sie autonom
selbst bestimmt eigenverantwortlich
voller Zurechenbarkeit handeln wollen
dann müssen sie her oder Herrin ihrer
selbst sein das heißt Sie sollten Sie in
der Regel nicht im Affekt tun aber Sie
können es vielleicht mit Emotionen
verbinden und wenn sie es eben jetzt
noch mal rückblickend aus Mitleid getan
haben ihre Handlung dann können sie
sagen ich habe es ge als autonomes Wesen
insofern ich mich darin als
leidensfähiges Wesen verstanden habe im
Grunde
und weil Mitleid ein Ausdruck meines
Vermögens ist
mich als leidensfähiges Wesen mit
anderen leitfähigen Wesen an Verbindung
zu bringen deswegen könnte man sagen ist
Mitleid unter einer bestimmten
Perspektive autonom wenn wir uns eben
die Schopenhauer ist tot lang nicht alle
Philosophen Philosophen aber schon
gehabt tut es wenn wir uns als im Grunde
als leidensfähige Wesen verstärken dann
wären wir im Mitleid autonom weil wir
darin unser eigenes Wesen ausdrücken
jetzt gibt's natürlich die Achtung von
jemand bekannten Immanuel Kant würde
sagen wir finden nur dann in einer
Emotion ein adäquaten Ausdruck unsere
Automobil ist das Gründe guten Gründe
verhandelt wenn wir uns darin als
Vernunft gewesen verstehen können das
heißt Autonomie unser eigenes Selbst
unser eigenes Gesetz ist nicht die
Leidensfähigkeit unserer selbst oder
andere Wesen das ist der Maßstab das
Mitleids vielleicht sogar die
Normativität wir kommen noch genauer
darauf zu sprechen kann würde sagen es
ist die Leidensfähigkeit die hier
diskriterium ist für unsere Autonomie
oder für unser Wesen sondern ist ist
unser Vernunft Zustand also ob wir uns
als Vernunftwesen verstehen ob wir eine
emotionale Einstellung eine emotionale
Haltung etablieren können in der wir
zugleich als vernünftige Wesen
erscheinen und nach kann ist es eben die
Achtung weil wir uns daran erhaben
fühlen wir haben durch unsere
vernünftige Seite und er haben zugleich
über unsere natürliche Seite Erhabenheit
ist ja eine Metapher die heißt dass wir
uns über etwas hinweg bewegt übersteigen
uns darin als Naturwesen auf unsere
vernünftig gewesen sind das wäre der
Autonomie emotionale Ausdruck der
Achtung und wir können natürlich noch
einen weiteren Zustand uns überlegen die
Liebe da verstehen wir uns als autonomen
dann wenn wir
harmonisch haben also das Kriterium für
Automobil ist im emotionalen mit der
Liebe die harmonische Verfasstheit
unserer
seelenvermögen unsere gesamten Vermögen
unsere Vernunft müssen uns mit unserem
Gefühl in einer harmonischen
Stimmung sein es muss gestimmt sein und
erst dann wenn wir innerlich harmonisch
sind sind wir nach Schiller oder auch
nach Harry Franco Gründe der Liebe
eigentlich autonomen und eigentlich auch
dann ist moralisch
ich fasse jetzt noch mal kurz zusammen
diese drei möglichen Emotionen die immer
auch Formen unsere Autonomie sind je
nachdem was wir als unser eigenes nicht
ansehen nach Schopenhauer ist es Mitleid
die einzig echte moralischen Fehler im
Mitleid identifizieren wir uns mit allen
leidenden Wesen nicht nur mit Menschen
sondern auch mit Tieren und das ist das
Problem der Achtung in der Achtung
können wir uns nur identifizieren mit
anderen Vernunft Wesen aber nicht mit
Tieren das heißt ein Tier leiden sehen
können wir zumindest nach Kant nicht
unmittelbar aus Achtung diesen Tier
helfen weil wir vor ihm keine Achtung
empfinden können weil das Tier eben
keine Vernunft hat ist nicht menschliche
Tiere dieses Problem geht es bei Mitleid
nicht die Mitleid reflektieren wir nicht
zu sehr das muss man auch noch sagen
sondern wir werden recht unmittelbar
seine Handlung angetrieben deswegen hat
Mitleid eine ganz starke affektive
Komponente affektiv ohne groß zu
reflektieren das kann man jetzt ein
bisschen noch genauer differenzieren
inwiefern spielt bei Mitleid vielleicht
doch noch eine Reflexion eine Rolle
warum könnte Reflexionen Mitleid eine
Rolle spielen ganz einfach weil wir uns
ja mit was identifizieren das heißt wir
haben da so eine Art Erkenntnis die
beteiligt ist nämlich wie erkennen uns
als im Grunde identisch mit einem
anderen Wesen weil das auch leidet und
in dieser Identifikation mit einem
anderen Wesen ist natürlich auch eine
Form von Reflexion enthalten ja so
könnte man wieder ein bisschen mehr
diese emotionale Seite gegenüber der
unreflektierten affektiven Seite stark
machen Mitleid ist jedenfalls eine sehr
starke Emotion und sie ist nach
schrobenhauer intrinsisch gut Mitleid
kann nie nach Schopenhauer zu einer
Moral schlechten Handlung führen wenn
Mitleid der Grunde Handlung ist dann ist
die Handlung auf jeden Fall gut zu
nehmen das kann man auch natürlich
problematisieren ob es innen drin sich
gute Emotionen gibt also Emotionen die
als solche an sich immer schon gut sind
und Schopenhauer sagt das ist das
Mitleid
Mitleid drückt unseren Willen im Grunde
aus der sich mit allen anderen
leidensfähigen Wesen identifiziert das
ist so der der Grund der ist Mittler der
Gegner steht jetzt die Achtung nach
Kante ist die Achtung die einzige echte
moralische Triebfeder und nicht das
Mitleid wie Schopenhauer behauptet hatte
Achtung ist
gefühlt
erzeugtes Gefühl er sagt es ein Gefühl
ich würde ihr sagen eine rationale
Option und Achtung geht nur vernünftigen
und moralischen Wesen nicht allen
leidensfähigen Wesen also mit einem Bund
sagt zumindest kann kann ich keine
Achtung vor einem Hund kann ich nicht
Achtung empfinden im moralischen Sinne
weil der Hund keine Vernunft hat
zumindest keine moralische Vernunft hat
vielleicht instrumentelle Vernunft er
weiß wie am besten zu seinem Futter
kommt das ist Instrument
telefonistinalität aber nicht moralische
Rationalität wir achten uns in der
Achtung im Grunde selbst sagt kann
sofern wir moralische Düsen sind wir
achten also eigentlich uns selbst aber
nicht uns selbst als Individuum sondern
als 5 Wesen in insofern wir mit allen
anderen von uns Wesen identisch sind als
auch hier gibt es bei Kant wie bei
Schopenhauer so eine Identifikation mit
anderen und ein übersteigen und das
Egoismus aber eben gerade in die andere
Richtung also zur Vernunft hin und nicht
zum Leiden hin zu der Neigung hin
Achtung besitzt im Gegensatz zu Mitleid
eine stärker sagt meine Stärke reflexive
Dimension im Sinne des Wert Erkennens
und wird Fühlens in der Achtung fühlen
wir den moralischen Wert
also wir fühlen die Moral wir fühlen den
absoluten Wert bin auch eine andere
Person hat also der Zweck an sich selbst
der wird hier in der Achtung erkannt
emotional spürbar und nicht nur
theoretisch erfassbar wie es ihm durch
den kategorischen Imperativ ausgedruckt
ist ja und jetzt kommen noch zum Schluss
zur Liebe die Liebe ist nach dem
Fremdwort und auch nach Friedrich
Schiller eine Emotion in der wir uns
verpflichtet fühlen ohne darin nur
orange sein zu müssen also das
verpflichtet sein dass es wieder Thema
Normativität auf dass wir heute noch am
Ende zu sprechen kommen sich
verpflichtet fühlen heißt da gibt's eine
richtige oder gibt's ein
eine Art von Gebot dass wir vernehmen
aber dieses Gebot sagt jetzt zumindest
Frankfurt und ich glaube auch Schiller
das ist nicht nur moralisch sondern es
kann auch in ganz verschiedenen
Kontexten eine Rolle spielen die Liebe
die ist nicht nur ein moralischen
Kontexten zu Hause Liebe drückt unsere
individuelle Verpflichtung gegeneinander
geliebten Person aus also liebe hat
stärker als die Achtung eine
individuelle Komponente ohne dass damit
Egoismus ausgedrückt wäre weil der Liebe
immer noch selbst Zwecke eine Rolle
spielt und nicht nur Mittel zum Zweck
nicht nur instrumentelle Rationalität
Liebe und Vernunft schließen sich nicht
aus sagen diese beiden Philosophen viel
mehr liefert uns die Liebe gute
normative und motivationale Gründe für
unser Handeln muss natürlich groß
geschrieben werden das waren diese drei
Kardinal Emotionen sagen mal das sind
ganz wichtige Emotionen die für unser
Handeln ganz wichtig sind zumindest in
der Geschichte der Philosophie wir
können uns jetzt weitere Emotionen
gleich noch überlegen nachdem ich ihm
noch mal hier ihre eigene Umfrage
präsentiere also die eigenen
Umfrageergebnisse
sie sehen also ziemlich klar
Mitleid ist der Sieger Achtung und Liebe
folgen aber die Liebe folgt noch vor der
Achtung also wenn ich es recht sehe
würden Sie sagen die Achtung ist viel zu
abstrakt und zu wenig konkret als dass
sie uns wirklich gut zu moralischen
Handlung bewegen kann immer jetzt eine
kurze diskussionspause dass man darüber
noch mal kurz diskutieren
ja wir haben uns jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen diese Umfrage angeschaut und
wir gehen jetzt weiter zum Schluss aber
nur ausblickshaft weil wir natürlich in
der virtuellen ersatzsitzung von morgen
noch mal alles ausführlicher behandelt
sehen werden heute und vor allem morgen
geht es um das Thema
Normativität und ich möchte auch nur
kurz ein paar einleitende Worte sagen
alle weiteren Details finden Sie dann
auf der
Ilias Seite oder auf filocast morgen ab
12 13 Uhr auf Videocast wird's
automatisch freigeschaltet auf
Ilias finden Sie es jetzt schon ähm ich
möchte nur so ein paar einleitende Worte
sagen zum Begriff der Normativität also
Normativität haben Sie bestimmt schon
mal gehört das kommt von lateinisch
normal
hat nichts mit dem Einkaufsladen zu tun
Norma oder vielleicht doch
muss man sich darüber unterhalten ist es
der Maßstab für gutes günstiges
Einkaufen ja kann man sich fragen
Richtschnur bedeutet es auch Maßstab
regelvorschrift und auch nur übertragen
Sinne liest man im Wörterbuch rechter
Winkel also rechter Winkel ist der Norm
Winkel wenn der Winkel eben den sie bei
Häusern hier bauen im eckwände eben nur
80 Grad hat dann ist eben die Decke so
ein bisschen China die Wand ein bisschen
schief und dann stimmt das ganze System
nicht mehr also muss ich an etwas
ausrichten jetzt kann man sich natürlich
fragen diese geldung und Verbindlichkeit
die eben Normativität aus was für ein
Status hat die ist die objektiv absolut
gültig diese Normativität oder es ist
nur eine Konvention dass man drauf
geeinigt haben die Frage stellt sich
natürlich vor allem bei moralischen
Normativität also moralischen Raum
Normativität bezeichnet Bereich des
sonnens als immer da wo Normativität
Auftritt sollen wir etwas tun aber wir
können es in ganz verschieden Kontexten
sollen nämlich im moralischen das ist
die engere Kontext das ist auch der
anspruchsvollste Kontext die
anspruchsvollste Normativität bei
moralischen Normativität häufig
universale Geltung also nicht nur hier
in Konstanz gilt diese Moral sondern auf
der ganzen Welt noch mehr für alle
vernünftigen Wesen sollte diesen
moralischen Raum Geld die politische
Normativität es gibt aber natürlich auch
ästhetische Normativität also was das
Kriterium dafür ist das etwas schön ist
und da sehen sie wie schwierig es wird
ästhetische Normativität zu begründen
über Geschmack lässt sich streiten und
warum soll dieses eine moderne Gemälde
wo schwarze Klecks auf eine weißen Wand
ist warum soll das höre ästhetische
Kunst sein als ein Gemälde aus dem 14
Jahrhundert ja da sehen sie da wird's
dann schon sehr sehr
schwierig moralische also ästhetische
Normativität zu denken es gibt jetzt
drei Fragen auf die gehen wir in der
virtuellen Sitzung ein aber auch in der
Sitzung nächst Mittwoch weil der Hammer
zweite Sitzung zu diesem großen schweren
schwierigen Thema wir haben drei Fragen
wie können wir Normativität begründen
und wir konzentrieren uns hier vor allem
auf moralische Normativität also
moralisches sollen wir können mal die
begründen dass das Begründungsproblem
dann gibt es das geltungsproblem für wie
gilt die Normativität
gilt die für alle Menschen oder erst ab
8 Jahren kleine Kinder sind nicht die
liegt fähig ja also gilt für Tiere
welche Tiere geht's vor Außerirdische
welche Eigenschaften müssen diese Wesen
haben damit für Sie die moralische
Normativität gelten kann und drittens
wie können wir Normativität erkennen das
ist das Erkenntnisproblem ja diesen drei
Fragen müssen wir uns dann näh
beschäftigen wir können sagen dass wir
moralische Normativität begründen können
durch Verweis auf Rationalität
Universalität und Autonomie und dabei
möchte ich es heute bewinden lassen also
es gibt so drei Strategien moralische
oder auch überhaupt Normativität zu
begründen indem sie sagen das ist das
eigentlich von vernünftige das ist die
Vernunft die das will die das fordert
daraus können Sie das sonnenableit aus
der Rationalität natürlich stellt sich
die Frage was ist Rationalität und
welche Rationalität und so weiter und so
fort sie können das über Universalität
sein das gilt für alle also Normativität
muss ja immer für viele Geld nicht nur
Individuen das ist ja nicht kompatibel
mit Normativität wenn ich sage es geht
nur für mich das sollen betrifft nur
mich dann könnte man schlecht von
Normativität reden Gebote gelten in der
Regel für viele Menschen und
idealerweise moralisch für alle
und Autonomie man könnte so
argumentieren sagen ja in der
Normativität da wird unsere Freiheit
auch irgendwie ausgedrückt und unsere
Autonomie also wenn wir und dieser
Normativität Folgen dieser moralischen
dann handeln wir eigentlich autonom das
wäre auch eine Möglichkeit moralische
Normativität zu begründen wir gehen dann
genauer darauf ein natürlich haben wir
hier wieder ein Philosophen der uns als
beispieldienst Sie ahnen ist immer man
kann den kategorischen Imperativ haben
Sie schon mal gehört den können wir dazu
nutzen diese drei Probleme diese drei
Fragen genauer zu beantworten ja dann
sind wir für heute am Ende angelangt
diesmal ziemlich pünktlich ich bedanke
mich für die Aufmerksamkeit und wünsche
Ihnen noch eine schöne Rest